Captain America Iron Man Thor and now
spider-man Doctor Strange a black
panther if you think the Marvel Universe
has become a superhero sausagefest you
may be in luck it seems everyone's
favorite redheaded assassin may finally
get her own movie I'm Simon and this is
your superhero news update Captain
America Civil War is in theaters now and
fans can expect nine more Marvel movies
to release between now and 2019 in an
interview with deadline Marvel President
Kevin Feige was asked which characters
might be next to get their own solo
movie after the Cinematic Universe is
third phase where we go beyond 2019 our
ongoing discussions that we'll focus on
in the next few years because we have a
lot to do before then of the characters
you just mentioned Falcon Warmachine
Black Widow and Hawkeye I would say
certainly the one creatively and
emotionally that we are most committing
to doing is Black Widow
Feige added that Marvel thinks she's an
amazing character and that Scarlett
Johansson's portrayal of her is amazing
she's a lead Avenger and has amazing
stories in her own right to tell but we
think would be fun to turn into a
standalone franchise a list of the
sheduled Marvel films is as follows
Captain America Civil War is currently
in cinemas with Doctor Strange due out
in November this year in 2017 we'll see
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 in May
spider-man homecoming arrived in July
and thor ragnarok smashing onto our
screens in November 2018 will make ways
of black panther in February Avengers
infinity War part 1 in May and then
ant-man and wasp in July the last of the
so far scheduled Marvel films in 2019
will be Captain Marvel out in March and
Avengers infinity War part 2 in May
Captain America Civil War directors Joe
and Anthony Russo are set to direct the
Avengers infinity war films and have
confirmed that the two movies are very
different and will be renamed before
they open in theaters
it looks like the cinema will be heavily
saturated with super-powered substance
for the coming years are you excited or
do you feel there are just too many
heroes and not enough heroines on the
list let me know in the comments or come
find me on Twitter I'm at the jaqen or
thanks for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it GameSpot's